Please give me the dosage for one bottle of para-clear. You recommend it. I take I weigh 99 pounds.
Okay, so the pros and cons of para-clear. So para-clear is our private labeled
nutritional, herbal, antiparasitic, antibacterial, can be an antifungal, can be an anti-viral.
The reason why I like it so much is that it has so many different herbs in there that are
known, antibacterial, antibacterial, antibacterial. The reason why I
say it's a negative is because it has so many and it's a low dosage of each one of those things.
So, you know, let's say you make a capsule and it's just vitamin C and no filler whatsoever,
you know, you could get, you know, several thousand milligrams of vitamin C in it.
But if you make a capsule and you have 15 different ingredients, well, you can only get one
15th of everything in that capsule. So you have to take more capsules really to get to the
dosage to be a, you know, a healthy dose to kill a parasite. So that being said,
para-clear has a lot in there. So it's killing parasites and other pathogens through multiple
different metabolic pathways. The negative again is that chips take a lot of them. So, but the
positive is when you're dealing with parasites or pathogens, you're typically are not taking it
at a daily basis. It's not like something you're going to stay on the rest of your life. You may go
through a half a bottle of it. You may go through one bottle of para-clear and that's all you're
going to take. So you have to take a fairly healthy dose. So given 99 pounds, how many should you take?
Well, the amount you should take is not totally just based upon weight. It's based upon tolerance,
nutritional and supplemental tolerance also. The bottle, it comes in a bottle, para-clear comes
in a bottle of 180 capsules because it's mid, you know, your ex-take a lot, many multiple capsules.
Other bottle, I think it says, serving size is three capsules. But if somebody was 200 pounds,
they may have to take, you know, 12 to 15 of them a day. Maybe they're only going to take six a day.
It depends on what you're dealing with. So if you're dealing with a possible, I love para-clear for
H. Pylora infection, which is a bacteria, but it's got a lot of stuff in there that is good for H. Pylora.
But you have to take it with your 99 pounds. You have to take at least six a day.
And you would maybe only do six a day per week, and then you might drop off completely and see
how you feel. See how that might change your symptoms. So like, for instance, I take para-clear,
but I might only take it like three or four days out of the month and then I don't take it for a while.
Or I might take it a day and I take six or eight of them and then I don't take it for another week
and then I take six or eight or nine of them and then I don't take it for another week. So that's how
I take it just because everybody has parasites. Everybody has pathogens and it's a good thing to
help just balance your gut. But if you know you're dealing with an active parasite or active
pathogen, you might feel like H. Pylora is rising up at me that I'll then I would take it for
a longer period of time. But at 99 pounds, I'd still say you take three to six a day,
depends on how active your whatever you're dealing with is and then drop it down and then you
can pulse it. So maybe that you'd only take it three days a week and then you feel like you're
getting better completely and you feel like you're over that then you maybe stop completely and
you put a new comment and you use it as needed. So typically anti-paracidic things like this,
you're not going to take continuously on a daily basis. I guess this is something you could take
on a daily basis if you just took water two of them. But it's going to have less effect than you
don't take you to high dose and try to kill something that's there.